series 2 of strange new worlds is going
to have kirk in it
what the hell are they doing at star
trek
welcome to sidetrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
if you are a regular sidetracker you're
going to know that i'm not the biggest
fan of prequels
i think actually for canon they're a
complete damn nightmare and i would
rather they just made a new tv show but
they haven't they've made strange new
worlds and i thought you know what hey
maybe this would be okay maybe they're
just going to show us how kirk became
captain they're going to show us those
few years running up to him taking over
the enterprise and moving into the
original series
but now we find out that no kirk is
actually going to appear in this series
now this is official paul wesley
who you may know from the vampire
diaries
i don't know him from the vampire
diaries because i'm not a teenage girl i
never actually watch the show um has
been cast and has actually been filming
already for series two now we've not
even since series one yet but yes series
two strange new worlds
filming is well underway
so the first question we have to ask is
when in the hell
is strange new world set
so let's think about the timeline here
pike became captain of the enterprise in
2250
everything that we saw that happened in
discovery happened in 2257. so i assumed
strange new worlds would be set in 2258
and onwards i thought that was a logical
assumption because that would have then
given us actually seven years until
where the original series started or
very least where we see pike in the
original series because the menagerie
episodes of the original series were
supposedly
set in 2267.
now kirk is supposed to have taken over
the captaincy of the enterprise in 2265.
now
that timeline would have been quite good
22.58 to 22.65 seven years a lovely
round number for star trek series
but kirk
has appeared
he does appear in photos that we've seen
sat aboard the captain's chair he does
seem to wear a captain's uniform
so that would suggest that strange new
orleans is actually set a little bit
later than we thought maybe the early
2260s and the first series is going to
be pike
but from the second series onwards kirk
now
that just annoys me because basically
what we're now talking about is instead
of a prequel it's a remake they're
remaking the original series
or are they or is this just some sort of
trick is paul wesley not actually going
to be a recurring character we don't
really know yet he might not be captain
kirk
see in the actual statement it just says
we welcome him
as james tabiris cook and we're really
going to hope to see what he can do with
this iconic character it doesn't call
him captain kirk now is that on purpose
because this show strange new worlds is
one that i know a lot of people are
excited about i'm not hugely excited
about it i think it's going to be just
another [ __ ] show but let's see i really
want to be wrong because you know i
thought picard series 2 is going to be
rubbish and so far i've only seen two
episodes but it's absolutely fantastic
so maybe kurtzman has learned his lesson
maybe strange new world is going to be
exactly what we hoped a marrying between
the original series and the new star
trek that we get today something that we
actually want to see
and in that case what does this kirk
thing mean because if it is based in
2258 roughly this is only a year after
the farragut incident where kirk nearly
died
he was an ensign at that point so he
should still be an incident now
now we can ignore the jj abrams star
trek and all that with the enterprise
because obviously that made no sense at
all the way he became captain there
but for the series it does need to be
fleshed out we do need to understand how
he's become the captain now now i would
love to see how kirk becomes captain i'd
love to see maybe even his first year
the run-up towards the original series
starting that could be what happens at
the end of this series run
but instead they're doing it in series
two so what the hell do we make of that
now i'm sure more details are going to
be coming out soon but right now it
really looks like strange new worlds is
all set to pee all over canon once again
so get into comments please tell me what
you think this news means because to me
it makes no sense at all
i really want to know what you think
guys
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit the bell notification
and please consider becoming a
sidetracker where you can support the
channel hit the join button now and as
always guys please stay safe i'll see
you soon